[Musique]
je m'appelle daniel lesur farmer et je
suis né qu'à winnipeg au manitoba
la famille de ma mère vieille de
saint-boniface un bastion francophone au
coeur de la ville de winnipeg et sa mère
vient de la gamme des mauriers et des
terriens de la broquerie quand ma mère
était petite elle habitait au coin du
moulin et saint jean baptiste
elle allait à l'école primaire saint
jean baptiste et pour aller chez eaton
elle traversait le pont provencher la
main agrippés à celle de sa mère pareil
comme dans l'autobiographie de gabrielle
roy donc quelques fois par mois elle
traversait le pont et de l'autre côté
ma mère entend des langues qui lui était
jusque là complètement étrangères
l'anglais
quelques années plus tard comme ma mère
avec 12,1 son père raymond le saut un
breton un peu misanthrope c'est bord a
décidé d'acheter un terrain à kenora
dans le nord ouest de l'ontario à 2h de
winnipeg pour y construire un motel il
ya donc déménager sa belle bande de
femmes quatre petites le saut et une à
venir une maman henriette à kenora où il
y avait peu un show qui parlait français
et ben du territoire à des frci
c'est là que ma mère a appris l'anglais
sans vraiment avoir le choix
ma mère nicole marianne le saut est
devenu dans la bouche de ces enseignants
de ces classes mais soyons de ses
camarades de classe
bref pour les gens de kenora ma mère est
devenue l'équipe le saut et c'était bon
malgré elle la langue maternelle y
rester le français mais dans la vie de
tous les jours dans la vie
professionnelle amoureuse et l'anglais
l'emporter et oui ma mère a rencontré
jim farmer de cleveland ohio et ensemble
ils ont formé leur sofa ma famille avec
moi
gagnaire jean aymé soeur christine elle
s'applique à ottawa où on a grandi
ma mère a travaillé fort pour garder le
français en vie comme on dit mais
c'était un peu de force comme toutes nos
activités et toutes nos amis notre
voisinage
ça se passait en anglais et c'était
juste lake les yeux c'est vrai on allait
à l'école en français l'école
élémentaire cabrio le roi mais
maintenant que je pense à ça je me dis
que je savais pas qui j'étais dans un
sens linguistique
je savais que en français c'est ce que
les professeurs crise dans les corridors
dans la cour de récréation
je savais que dans les manuels de
géographie d'histoire
les francophones d'amérique c'est que
des québécois mais je j'avais juste
jamais entendu parler des francophones
du manitoba ou de l'ontario même si j'en
étais un saut de 6 me à 12,3 new york
speak french l'école ma mère il disait
c'est comme ça c'est important
à l'adolescence c'est devenu beaucoup
plus clair
maintenir le français c'était comme
beaucoup trop difficile pour beaucoup de
gens c'était juste
comme tout au royaume uni elle est
animée xen
l'autre jour j'étais dans un bar à
ottawa puis j'ai dit bonjour à la
serveuse ça m'a répondu bonjour on a
continué notre conversation en anglais
comme c'est souvent le cas à tahoua pas
tout le temps mais souvent et à l'eau
fini par me dire que son père était
francophone
qu elle se souvient d'avoir parlé
français quand tu es petit mais que
c'était loin dans son esprit que dans le
fond et sexe qu'elle l'ait perdu son
français au final